es un tenso y acalorado debate uno que
se disputa tanto en las calles como en
el parlamento con pancartas que se lee
apártate de mi inmunidad natural y no al
pase de la vergüenza cientos marchan en
parís hacia la asamblea nacional y
dentro del hemiciclo dejen de
interrumpirse
los parlamentarios estaban igualmente
divididos la decisión de requerir
vacunas obligatorias para los
trabajadores de la salud tuvo algo de
apoyo pero el pase sanitario o el
requisito de mostrar prueba de
vacunación o examen negativo de kobe 19
enardeció a algunos un diputado incluso
incitó a los protestantes a tomarse el
parlamento para el ministro de salud del
tiempo juega en contra con más de 20.000
nuevos contagios en las últimas 24 horas
frente al individualismo elijamos la
responsabilidad colectiva avancemos
examinando este proyecto de ley tecno
las herramientas para proteger a los
franceses el gobierno quiere acelerar
este proyecto de ley la oposición dice
que no se les está dando el tiempo
suficiente con más de mil enmiendas el
estridente debate se extendió a altas
horas de la noche del miércoles el
partido socialista siente que el pase
divide a la población en dos ellos
prefieren que la vacuna sea un requisito
para todos a partir de septiembre para
el extrema derecha la situación política
es la culpable para el extremo izquierda
emanuel macrón está jugando con el
autoritarismo pues necesitamos algo más
en un monarca que desde el palacio del
elíseo da órdenes a sus subordinados
bajo la luz del primer ministro francés
dice que buscará la opinión del consejo
constitucional pero advirtió que la
cuarta ola ya azota francia
para que el pase sanitario convenza a
los escépticos de la vacuna que
conforman el 96% de los nuevos contagios
a inocularse